(laughing)
- You're fine, you're fine.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
What the (bleep) am I doing?
(quirky music)
- [Cameraman] I'm gonna
zoom in on the sign
and then you're gonna
walk from the entrance
right next to the car.
- Right here?
Cool, alright.
- Yeah, right next to the car.
It's gonna look cool, right?
- [Cameraman] Yeah.
(quirky music)
- Hey there, I'm Aria and
I'm fascinated by love,
in particular the idea of a Vegas wedding.
And I figure what better way
to get the full experience
than to marry a stranger here in 24 hours.
Mike, right?
- Hey, Aria.
- [Aria Voiceover] To
begin this adventure,
I get a quick tour of the chapel
I will be getting married in tomorrow.
- Where you will be standing
here tomorrow is right here.
- Right here.
- You get everything all in one.
That's the reason why people do it here.
It's incredible value, tons
of fun, tons of energy.
That's why people come
here and do it in Vegas.
- Do you think I'll be
able to find someone?
- Oh, for sure, yeah.
For sure, you're in Vegas, man.
(quirky music)
- [Aria Voiceover] Despite
Mike's confidence in me
not only do I have to
find someone to marry
in less than 24 hours,
but there's another
obstacle I have to tackle.
- So obviously I don't
wanna actually get married.
I'm not that crazy.
I'm crazy, just not that crazy.
And so basically I need
to find someone to marry
in a way that meets the
terms for an annulment.
So I've done my research
and from what I understand
there are several ways
you can get an annulment
here in the state of Nevada,
and one that jumps out
at me is here it says
there are grounds for annulment include
if you or your spouse was
married to someone else
at the time of your marriage.
So I'm thinking if I marry
someone who's already married
I can get married without
it actually counting
as a real marriage.
Right?
- Mm-hmm.
- Right?
- If I find someone who's legally married,
if I marry them, the marriage
actually won't count,
is that correct?
- [Mandy] Correct, yes.
It would definitely be a void marriage.
If you're married to somebody else legally
even in another state
and you get married in a different state
it's considered a void
marriage, the second one.
- So on that note Mandy, is
there any chance you're married
and free tomorrow from two to three for--
(laughing)
- [Mandy] Well, tomorrow from two to three
I'm actually in court.
(laughing
- Oh.
(laughing)
I'm not crazy.
You're looking at me like I'm crazy, Ryan.
Do you think this is crazy, Ryan?
- It's a little crazy.
- Do you think I'm crazy, Cidro?
- Just a little bit.
(clap)
- I'm not crazy.
I'm not crazy.
- [Aria Voiceover] After I
failed to convince myself
of my sanity
I began my hunt to find a
married woman to marry me.
- I've joined every Facebook
group I can for parents,
married couples here in Las Vegas.
I've also hit up Craiglist.
I'm looking at meet-up groups
and just hopefully at least one person,
hopefully one person,
hopefully one person gets back to me.
Most likely I'm just gonna get banned
from a bunch of Facebook
groups but oh well.
- [Aria Voiceover] Not wanting
to call it a night just yet
I decided to try our luck after dinner
with a quick pit stop.
(quirky music)
Unfortunately, since it's a weeknight,
I'm only able to find a
couple of people to chat with.
- I'm hoping to get married tomorrow.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Congratulations.
- Congratulations!
- Well, thank you, sort of.
I don't have anyone to marry yet.
(laughing)
I'm wondering if either of you are married
and free tomorrow from
2-3 p.m. to marry me.
(laughing)
- I'm not married.
- I'm not.
- [Aria Voiceover] Despite striking out
I actually get some helpful perspectives.
- I think people are
drawn to Vegas weddings
for the immediate gratification,
the spur of the moment,
happening right now.
- The wedding's for you
and the other person.
It's not for everybody else you know
and that's a very intimate time
and I just love the idea
that you can actually be able
to do it in such a spontaneous
and still really cool way.
It is truly the most humbling
and exciting experience
to be able just to run
off with that person
or the few people that mean
the most to you in your life
and just share those
moments with each other.
(peaceful music)
(quirky music)
- We're here on The Strip right now.
It is 9 a.m.
We're just hours away from the wedding,
trying to find someone to marry.
It's hectic, a lot of
nos, people are going by
and it's turning into a bit of a struggle.
Excuse me.
Are either of you married?
And I'm wondering are you both married?
- Yes.
- You're both married?
- 20 years.
- 20 years!
Fantastic.
- Yes.
- Seven years.
- Seven years, perfect.
I'm just wondering if you two are married
and if one of you is
free to get married to me
today between 2 and 3 p.m.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh no.
(laughing)
- No, we're not married.
- You're not married?
Alright, well that won't work.
- No, we couldn't.
(laughing)
- Are you guys free to get...
- I don't know, are we?
- Two and three?
- Yeah.
- I don't think so.
- No, we're not?
- Wish you well on your marriage.
- [Aria] Thank you very
much, I appreciate it.
- Wish you 20 years.
- [Aria Voiceover] With
the clock running out
I grow increasingly frustrated
and I'm just about ready
to give up when suddenly--
- Okay, so we actually just got a response
on one of the Facebook groups
I posted in last night.
This guy Omar responded to
it and says he's not in Vegas
but would love to share and
tags this woman named Nikika.
Nikika responded and says that
she'd love to meet with us,
she gives an email address
and says please feel free
to contact me with any other info needed.
(quirky music)
Hi, is this Nikika?
- Hi, this is Nikia.
- Oh, is it Nikika?
- It's Nikia.
- Oh, hi Nikia.
Thank you so much for
sending in that message.
So from what I understand you are married.
Is that correct?
- Yes, I am.
- Fantastic.
- And you would be free
to come marry me today
between 2 and 3 p.m.?
- [Nikia] Darling, I'm
gonna come and marry you.
- I'm so happy about
this, thank you so much.
You're definitely married though.
- [Nikia] Yes, I am definitely married.
We look forward to it, thank you so much.
- Thank you, we'll see you soon.
- [Nikia] You're welcome.
- Bye-bye.
Getting married!
This is love in Vegas!
This is love!
- [Aria Voiceover] We meet
up with Nikia and her wife
back at the chapel, who both
turn out to be a lot of fun.
- I'm in a lesbian marriage
so if I get the opportunity to marry
one hot straight guy, why not?
- You're very sweet.
- [Aria Voiceover] Nikia and
Monica are newlyweds themselves
and seem to have a great relationship.
- I mean, just the thought
of being able to express
and show love in its natural
form is just awesome.
So I thought it would
be a great opportunity
to just share that experience with you.
- Something that we both share that we
want to share to others that
love still exists in the world.
- Yeah.
- To be honest.
- It's a beautiful thing.
- [Aria Voiceover] So
with an hour to spare
I'm thrilled that we somehow
managed to pull it off.
- She's beautiful.
- She's looking beautiful?
- Yeah, she's looking good.
- That's my wife.
- [Aria Voiceover] I'm
also particularly happy
that I don't have to cancel
on the actors I hired
to be wedding guests.
Including those playing
the parts of my parents.
- It's still surreal
to me but I'm so happy
that you found your partner.
I've got mine.
(laughing)
- I am so glad you're both still alive
to be here with me today.
- Yes, yes.
- Well we're glad to be alive too.
(laughing)
- I love you both so much.
- We love you too, son.
- [Aria Voiceover] Finally,
after a crazy 24 hours,
the wedding begins.
♪ Wise men say, "Only fools rush in" ♪
- [Officiant] Aria, I want you to look
at your beautiful bride
and repeat after me.
I will never leave you, baby.
- I will never leave you, baby.
- Never leave you.
- At the Heartbreak Hotel.
- I will never, ever leave you.
- I will never, ever leave
you until after this ceremony.
(laughing)
- For Elvis.
- [Officiant] And now by
the power vested in me
by the State of Nevada,
I will now pronounce you husband and wife.
And you may now seal
your love with a kiss.
(laughter and applause)
- We're married!
(cheering)
♪ Bright light city gonna set my soul ♪
♪ Gonna set my soul on fire ♪
- [Aria Voiceover] The ceremony
takes less than 15 minutes
but it's ridiculously fun and
it's certainly an experience
I will never forget.
(cheering)
♪ One plus one to fly ♪
- I love you.
(kissing)
- Love you too.
♪ Over and over again ♪
- You're my best friend.
- [Aria Voiceover] But I
think what I learned most
is that it doesn't really
matter where you get married.
You can have a huge wedding or a small one
but ultimately all that actually matters
is that you're standing there
face to face, hand in hand,
with the person you love.
(applause)
- So if anyone out there is
planning on getting married
maybe consider a wedding like this.
Although, ideally you'll marry someone
who doesn't already have a spouse.
(quirky music)
Fun time.
(uplifting music)
I'm really happy right now.
(swiping)